hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to go
over the most common antidotes that you
want to know
as a nurse and this video is part of an
nclex review series over pharmacology
and as always whenever you get done
watching this youtube video you can
access the free quiz
that will test you over these antidotes
so let's get started
what are antidotes well to help us
understand that let's take this word
apart
the prefix anti means against and
dots means to give so when we put all
that together
we get to give against so antidotes are
substances that we can
give to work against some like
toxicities or overdose or poisoning
that is occurring in the body now what
we're covering in this video are the 14
most common antidotes you want to know
for your exams
and whenever you're working as a nurse
it's always important like if you're
going to be giving
some heparin warfarin or digoxin you
want to know in the back of your mind
okay
what is that antidote in case my patient
experiences
toxicity because you want to be able to
go and grab that fast
so first let's talk about digoxin so a
patient can have what we call dig
toxicity
and i talked in depth about digoxin in
another review
so if a patient has this this is a
cardiac glycoside what can we give to
help reverse those effects well it's
really easy to remember
it's called digibinds so whenever you
give that they'll reverse the effects
then we have heparin heparin is an
anticoagulant so it's a blood thinner
now it's a fine balance between having a
patient's blood too thin or too thick
but if they are having heparin like
toxicity where they have too much
on board we can give the antidote
protamine sulfate and that will help
reverse that
then we have warfarin and you may hear
this referred to as coumadin
this is also an anticoagulant so it
thins the blood
an antidote for this is vitamin k
definitely i remember those two then we
have benzodiazepines
and these are very strong sedative drugs
that are highly addictive
a lot of their medication names end in
pam pam
or lamb lam such as diazepam
and that's valium so if a patient takes
too much of this
they can have adverse effects and we can
give flumazonil that's the
antidote for those and then we have
opioids opioids just like benzos
are highly addictive they are
painkillers and we're talking about
drugs like morphine
fentanyl etc and we can give what's
called naloxone
for an antidote for that and you've
probably heard a lot about the opioid
issues that we have here in the u.s and
narcan
that's another name for this we can give
that to reverse the effects of opioids
then we have acetaminophen and here in
the u.s that is tylenol this is like a
painkiller you can take over the counter
so if a patient takes too much of this
say they're trying to
commit suicide overdose they we can give
them
what's called acetylcysteine and how i
remember this antidote
is that acetylcysteine has ace in it and
so does
acetaminophen so those two go together
and that helps me remember that
then we have beta blockers and these are
cardiac medications and they
end in lol like metoprol or atenolol
and if a patient gets too much of that
on board toxicity with that we can give
them glucagon
and how i remember that is that with
beta blockers remember
they mask hypoglycemia so glucagon like
glucose that's how i keep those two
straight
then we have anticholinergic toxicity
along with
cholinergic toxicity so these two
conditions are opposite of each other
so first anti-cholinergic so with this
this can be caused by like various
medications that
really affect those receptor sites and
cause anti-cholinergic effects but we
have
too much occurring in the body so we're
talking about like medications like
antihistamines
or atropine so if that happens we can
give what's called
physostigmine then on the flip side we
have
cholinergic toxicity and this can be
caused by substances like
organophosphates or
carbamates these are substances that are
typically found in insecticides
pesticides and they can be used to
poison people
so to help reverse that we can give
atropine then we have magnesium sulfate
and we talked a lot about this drug in
our ob lectures when we talked about
pre-eclampsia
so an antidote for that is calcium
gluconate and if you plan on working in
ob i would definitely remember that
antidote for magnesium sulfate
next is cyanide poisoning if a patient
has this
an antidote is hydroxyl cobalamin
then we have ethylene glycol or methanol
now ethylene glycol is found in like
antifreeze
and methanol is found in like windshield
wiper fluids so you're probably thinking
how would a person get too much of this
well they could accidentally ingest it
or intentionally ingest it like trying
to commit suicide or maybe they were
poison
like ethylene glycol with the antifreeze
if you have ever watched those like
forensic shows there's a lot of cases
where the person's being poisoned with
antifreeze with this ethylene glycol
so antidotes for these are faumepazole
and then lastly we have lead toxicity
and iron toxicity so lead toxicity too
much lead in the body
we can do what's called chelation
therapy and this is a method
where we can remove those heavy metals
from
the bloodstream so with lead we can give
like an oral
chelation medication called succimer
or calcium disodium edita and that's
via injection then with iron toxicity
an antidote for that is defyroxamine and
with differoxamine how i remember that
is with iron what's atomic number for
iron fe
so with this antidote you have fe in it
and that's how i remember
it's antidote okay so that wraps up this
review over the most
common antidotes you want to know as a
nurse and as always don't forget to
check out that free quiz that will test
you
on these antidotes